こんにちはう
頭がいいですはじめ社長です世の中にはいろんなスペシャリストはいると思うんですよ
僕みたいな人は youtube のスペシャリストと言っても過言ではありませんね
まあでもトップ主です特殊
覚えるんですね例えばものすごくネジに詳しい人がものすごく電球が好きな人でお仕事
とかでも何か一つに対するプロフェッショナルって人が必ずいるんですよ
プロフェッショナル
やっぱかっこいいじゃないですかで僕いろんなプロフェッショナルと配当に話し合い
たいと思ってますねどうすればそれができるのかなと思ったところあの世の中で一番
賢い奴ってなんだろうなと思ったら wikipedia なんですよ皆さんご存知
ですね wikipedia ウィキペディアにはこのようにあるありとあらゆる情報
すべて詰まっておりましてないものもあるんですけど大抵のことは3
ぴ者に全部あるんですよってことはこんな僕でも言ったハエがネットサーフィンと早い
んですよね僕のこの検索力を活かして
wikipedia を見ながら頃フェッショナ女の人の会話できればその会話の内容
がどんなに高度なものでも専門家から聞いた事をすぐ検索行きピーターにかけてもう
決して素人にはできない公募な対話がろふぇっしょなると僕で出来ると思うんで今日は
そんなウィキペディアの2
彼らを使ってどこまでプロフェッショナルな人と講座な会話ができるのかやってみよう
と思いますでは行こうよ
[音楽]
佐久間ケンイチと申します
pasar トレーナーです
えっと女性専用の大会とまたボディメイクを専門とする事務を運営
ダスッ
僕自身が驚異4スポーツをやっていて減量にとても振るシーンでまあそれで競技人生が
終わったっていうこともあるのでそのようにダイエットの知識を持たずに苦しんでいる
方を助けたいと思いまに至っております
スペインです
もしもし
申しますはじめまして初めまして肇社長と申しますよろしくお願いしますお願いします
集まるトレーナーのキャップまあと申します
パーサー noon ん
お食事をとりえたんですか
そうですねまぁ基本的に前に行こうとしたかったんでやっぱ直線100気を付けますね
あしゅ生が絶賛はい
世代的にどんなものを食べません
ネットですそうですね
pas
服はですね炭水化物制限とかしましたねあ追加無制限愛あれいいですよねあの
今にも糖尿病ジム有効な手段となるんで敗北は
炭水化物制限とてもいいなと思ってやってましたねそうですね5年前をば最近シーラン
ちゃん筋肉量も
を持って行こうかなーっありがとうございますそれ
と東進生と書使いました
糖新生党推薦ってもちろんですよねあの人や動物がグルカゴンの分泌しおっシグナルと
して
ビル p 参入3 o 原西は皆さんソロ美容3グリフィロールなどの欧州以外の物質
からグルコースを生産する手段と経路なくねそうですね交付制限を打っ
糖新生が
マークに比べると取りやすくなるじゃないですかん物のそうですよねそれ1た園舎を
保つために海とうとうが途切れます
あそうです運動をやってましたねそんなを
ねやっぱ13想像してました有酸素運動本1はティっにょと品に行くよ
てしまうので喧嘩ではニーズよねそうですよね赤い買われて言うとビッグ3は行って
ました
big 3 p くっいいかーえー
ぶーベッドいっすよねやっぱレアカー遠足とかのウェイトトレーニング
でもっと素で初めてはどんぐらいなんかペットリフトですかもう
特に好きながルーマニアンデットリフトですねをこれぐらいの重量でやってい
ブーブストリングと書き換えられるかなぁと思って撃っ
すごいすぅーっもう枯れ
ぱられかなーぐっぴょん
bea
あれでてこねぇやっぱり何運やでいろいろ知ってると楽しいですね会話も
今日ありがとうございましたありがとうございましたまずで by まってぼれず玉
行きペディアに乗ってもや作るのがマジでヤバいねこれこんなにマニアックなことが出
てくるたちと思わなかったです
はい高いところに荷物を置くと危ないよ
高荷智也と申します
備え防災アドバイザーという肩書で活動しております
個人と家庭の防災対策企業のリスク管理や bcp 対策を行う奉仕
執筆活動またはコンサルティングなどさせていただいていますはい
自然災害大国日本ではいつどんな災害に巻き込まれるかわかりませんでも防災対策は
楽しいことではありませんので出来るだけなくをしてやっていく必要があり
総裁をライフスタイルにするためのいろいろな提案をしていきたいなと思います
き価値が次行きましょう
me
th
もしもしもしもしはじめまして話してる状況なぁ
私肇社長と申しますユーチューバーですこちら私は大サイドバイザーという仕事をして
おりますハ神と申しますよろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いします
防災アドバイザーはい防災を色々とアドバイスをしようかをしています
あのもちろんご存知ですよ防災ってーいわゆる子がや資格みたいなものがないんじゃ
ないですか
まあないですね確かにダサい防災士の資格とかってお持ちだったりしますもしかして
持ってます持っています
そうですかじゃあ話が早いですね坊さん対策って実際の知識を入れるだけじゃなくって
執行をなさないと命が
が変わってくるものじゃないですかあのやっぱり防災て打つを買ってきてそれでよし
みたいにすればたすごく多いじゃないですかまあいませんあるだけで安心してる方多い
ですよね
そうなんですよフロアの気象庁から平気で寝る新しく導入されたありますねああ
もちろんほどんですよ
こっから涼しいですか入ってるんです基本的にある
米5段階に分かれてますけどねそうです実際あれ数字を言われたときにどこで判断し
たらいいかどの数字を言われたら逃げたらいいかってなかなかみんな考える基準が現れ
で難しいなぁと思うけど
をはじめさんだったらこの数字が出たところでなぁ始めるべきだっております
まあ僕は主にまあ警戒レベルにであればまあハザードマップトンネル災害が想定されて
いる区域や避難先の避難経路を確認するだけで良いのでにはまだ大丈夫だと思うんです
よ
あーまぁそうですよねでさんとなるとやはりあの依存2時間方
てしまいそうな高齢者等の形は自ら避難の判断をすべきかなと思いまして
まあ僕がまあレベル4からな気はしますねあーなるほどそうすると何かというから言わ
れてる全員非なると同じということですね
あっ
はい
そもそも避難をしなくていい形が立っているじゃないですか
ああ今つでやっぱりあのー南市全域
何十万人避難勧告避難指示が出ました
なってもう実際全員逃げてしまうと周囲をできないですよねまあそうですね避難場所に
も勝つで限りがありますからねぇ
そうなんですよその避難場所
っていうところも2種類いくんじゃないですか方位磁ではいもちろん事ですよ
今人として抑えられるって避難所と避難場所のはずですかねそうですです避難場所は
火災の場所やその他の危険から
をするための4セット場所を行ってまして避難所はですね避難場所とほぼ重なっちゃう
部分が多いんですよね
やっぱりこういうのって
みんな自分の家の近所に学校があるからそこに逃げればいいって思いが子じゃないです
か
まあそうですね近所の学校って避難所にはなってると思うんですけどならず下避難場所
には指定されてなかったりって言うと問題あるじゃないですか
そうだねそれは問題になってますねで何か津波から近所の学校に逃げたら実はそこ
ファシズム場所で避難場所としては適していなかったとかそういうのはやっぱりすごく
悲しいなぁと思って事前にみんなハザードランプ
もっと見てもらうをどこに入れたりとかっていうのがわかると思うんですよ
ハザード乗ってもいろいろと種類大蛇
偶然那覇竿とマックもうそれは別ね被害予測水地図別もんねそうですね
あの別名使うのは珍しいなって感じですけど近年が違いますよね
ああそうな彼へツリーの皆さんスマホ持っているのでスマホで歯がいいのマップを
もっと見たらいいなと思うんですけど
国土交通省のハザード待ってくださいと
になるじゃないですかああありますありますあれって二つ昨日はじゃないですかああ
ありますね
重ねるハザードマップとわがまちハザードマップですねそうなんですよそうなんですよ
重ねハザードマップをスマホでもって気楽に見えたら欲しいんじゃないかなんですよね
これに関してはアレですもんねと家の特徴や道路棒
詳細情報洪水土砂災害津波のリスク情報は同地図優しに自由に重ねて表示できるので見
やすいですよね
そうなんですよねただん最近台風
すごい多いじゃないですか台風で高潮の被害想定されてますけど剱よくて朝食や
パターンを待って対象外じゃない
あれで台風や発達した低気圧が会
願望通過する際に生じる解明な高まりですねそうですそうです
意外とあの肌度マップでまだ売り込むしているべきだなって
ていましてああ
そうですね津波しかありませんもんねそうなんですよ
やっぱり海に近いところにクーデレ硬くてご高潮にも警戒をしなきゃいけないと思う
それがあら町ハザードマップ常がハザードマップ良好で咲かせようになるとすごく
いいっ
感染しちゃったよ今日あったか話が良かったです
今日ありがとうございましたはいでございましたいやーねえ
山と聞いたが出しだねーのにめっちゃ
フォースね三高で出しちゃったんですけど意外に大切式が本当にすごいんでぜひとも
ちゃんと話は聞きたかったなと思いますね見てたが勉強になったというか今の会話だけ
ですごいレベルが上がった気がしましたそんな肌とパッと見とこ
春忍と申します
港区三田で皮膚科を開業しています
赤ちゃんの湿疹アトピー性皮膚炎ヤケドなどの普通の皮膚科の診療から私は特に美容
皮膚科
here on sun を専門とした綺麗になる診療しています
シェイなることで女性てがとても元気になってい
敏太郎が延期になってそこからやる気が出たりとか気になることは本当に生きてき喜び
であってもの額を良くしていくだと思っているのでみんなが幸せになることがとても
楽しくて
一生懸命やっています
日出です
武道
ブロリーキャラクターたちは用意していた
わかりましたメンサー隊員の避難するプランナー
僕もハイライザー
メンサ会員でして遺留分減殺請求
実験的な効果で対象物が共有になってフレが総会開催されては共有関係が発生時になり
でまぁ金銭的な請求傾向がある
入ってそのへんは自分的に造営デュアル
もう一度聞いてもいいですか
[音楽]
htg